"We face four historic crises all at the same time. This is going to take bold creative federal action."
Use your full authority. The people of this nationhave spoken. Now the work of making that vision is real.
Now that the disastrous presidencyof Donald Trump is likely coming to an end,
Joe Biden will get the chance to make good onhis promise to create bold change in the livesof all Americans.
On his first day in office, Biden says that he plans to roll back many ofTrump's signature policies
with his own sweepingexecutive orders, and he has promised to transformthe economy
to fight climate change, reassertAmerica's diplomatic and military power abroad,
and establish new federal offices like that ofa national supply chain commander
to centralize control of commercial industry in response tothe Coronavirus pandemic.
What is our mandate?
We're going to make historic investments so we'll seize the opportunity.
This will go down as one of the most progressive administrations in American history.
It's unclear what Biden will ultimatelybe able to accomplish as president,
but he hasalready spent 44 years as a senator and thenvice president,
trying to bring transformativechange through federal action in response tosupposed crises,
and his record on issues includingimmigration, the drug war, criminal justice reform,and foreign intervention
has been dismal. How canhe really be a progressive and want to lock thesepeople up?
And I'd say lock the S.O.B.'s up. Now we can find some fringe folks, libertarians, andleft wingers in my party who say
"No that's notwe should do," but politically that consensus hasbeen arrived at.
As the president-elect pushes anew ambitious agenda it's worth remembering theimpact
of the far-reaching laws he has repeatedlyhelped pass which have created enormous suffering
and exacerbated some of the most criticalproblems still afflicting American society.
We have predators on our streets. Increasethe penalties, increase them.
I would put the son of a gun in jail. Put them to death.
We have to hold every drug user accountable because if there were no no drug users,
there wouldbe no appetite for drugs there would be no market forthem.
In the 80's Biden sought to escalate thedrug war beyond what Ronald Reagan and GeorgeH.W. Bushhad called for.
The President says hewants to wage a war on drugs but if that's true,
what we need is another d-day not another vietnam.
And co-sponsored legislation that locked up tens of thousands of predominantly young black men
forminor crack possession.
Five years, no probation, no parole. If you have this much lock them up and put them in our prison.
In the 90's he led the chargeon a massive expansion of the death penalty.
A wag in the newspaper recently wrote, "Bidenhas made it a death penalty offense for everything but jaywalking."
And the militarization of law enforcement.
Let the FBI agents buy weapons aspowerful as the drug cartels had.
They get beat up.
I wrote the original bill that startedthis whole process. The so-called Biden crime bill.
The 1994 crime bill along with several otherpieces of legislation Biden pushed for
expanded mandatory minimum sentences, created three strikeslaws,
and drove up the local state and federal prison populations.
Biden crime bill. The Bidencrime bill. The Biden crime bill.
Every major crime bill since 1976, every minor crime bill has had thename of the democratic senator
from the state of Delaware, Joe Biden.
In the 2000's Biden played a key role in expanding warrant-less surveillance.
Just to set the record straight almost the same thing thatgot passed, the Patriot Act, was introduced by me
in 1994. Including the wiretap changes and the rest.
Starting disastrous foreign wars.
Saddam Hussein is still seeking the accumulation of weapons of mass destruction.
I do not believe this isa rush to war I believe it's a march to peace and security.
And building fences on the Mexican border.
Biden's only solution to critical issues overnearly five decades has been to grow the federalgovernment
in an attempt to remake society forthe better.
In reality his agenda has destroyed vulnerable communities and eroded civil liberties.
To hold our media accountable is something we alldesire but there's a thing called the First Amendment,
which is read in a way that I thinkis a little excessive.
Though today his policypriorities have again shifted with the democraticpolitical winds,
what has held constant isBiden's commitment to bold state intervention
in more areas of Americans lives.
These are interlocking crises of our time requires the president to defend us from every attack seen and unseen,
always and without exception.
And he's  never stopped telling us that it's all for our owngood.
The African-American community stood up again for me.
You've always had my back and I have yours.
They are in jail, away from my mother, your husband, ourfamilies. And my daughter will be safer,
my wife will be safer, my mother will be
safer, and I will be safer, and I will be happy."
Hand up, don't shoot. No justice, no peace.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
The younger generation now tells me howtough things are, give me a break. No no.
I have no empathy for it, give me a break becausehere's the deal guys,
we decided we were going to change the world and we did.
We did. We finished the civil rights movement to the first stage, the women's movement came to be.
So my messageis get involved. There's no place to hide.